i'm very pleased to say the defense
secretary ben wallace joins us once
again the program good to see you this
morning minister um i wonder if actually
we might start uh with a quick question
on on where mark was the translator in a
moldova border how concerned are you
that vladimir putin's ambitions stretch
much further than ukraine well i think
he's always had these sort of ambitions
that he wrote about and spoke about
for years actually about the russian
people or the ancient people of russian
that has led him to be sort of ethnic
nationalist when he drives towards sort
of geographic ambition it's one of the
justifications of why he thought he
would be able to walk into ukraine and
be welcomed and obviously there are
pockets of other russian speakers that
he feels uh potentially in the same way
that you know the nazis felt the second
world war that they have a sort of
ownership of these people uh and so
there is definitely a sense that you
know you can see in his current
statement he is in almost in desperation
trying to broaden this either with
threats or indeed with potential false
flags or or attacks we we don't know the
details of the attacks that happened
yesterday uh in china easter there are a
number of players in transparency there
are separatists there are russians
everything so we're not too sure
but of course it's another step if it is
russia behind it of of another example
of his strategic blunder because you
know for romania moldova is incredibly
important so all you do is harden the
resolve of something like romania we saw
him switch off the gas to bulgaria
yesterday which was a country that was
sort of on the fence well the
consequence of that is the complete
opposite is is this in part why the
foreign secretary kind of alluded
yesterday to the fact in this conflict
this war in ukraine could last a number
of years it could last perhaps a decade
well i think it's certainly the case
that putin having failed and nearly all
his objectives may seek to consolidate
what he's got sort of fortify and dig in
as he did in 2014
and just be a sort of cancerous growth
within the country of ukraine
and make it very hard for people to move
them out of those fortified positions so
i think it it's really about if if if we
want this to not happen we have to help
the ukrainians effectively get the
limpet off the rock
and keep the momentum pushing them back
but when liz trust says you know we have
to push russia out of the whole of
ukraine i mean we should we really need
to clarify this is she talking about
crimea well the international community
believes russia should leave ukraine the
international community has condemned
russia for its invasion of crimea which
was illegal in 2014
its invasion of danesque which
recognizing it as illegal is somewhat
different
and we've constantly said that russia
should leave uh
ukraine sovereign territory so that
hasn't changed we if you remember we did
a freedom of navigation exercise hms
defender last year in the black sea we
don't recognize their ownership so so
are you contemplating a point in this
conflict where we will continue to
support the ukrainians as they push into
crimea well i i think i mean you know
there's a long way to go before ukraine
cautions your crimea i think what i
would certainly say is you know we we
are supporting ukraine's sovereign
integrity we've done that all along that
of course includes crimea and danes but
you know first and foremost let's get
russia out of where they are now in its
invasion plans and help ukraine resolve
and that's if you remember the minsk
agreement which russia has basically
ripped up was all about trying to
resolve those two occupied territories
but the key thing is to continue to
support ukraine sovereign integrity and
their ability to defend themselves it
appears that you do have a bit of an
ally in the foreign secretary as you
would expect of course but when she said
in her speech you know that the two
percent in terms of nato spending should
be the floor and not the ceiling i mean
you would want more money at the moment
i'm just wondering has the treasury
served to provide you with funds
to replace the weapons and equipment
that we've sent to ukraine to cover the
cost of sending troops to the border yes
for now the treasury has absolutely
reimbursed us or are reimbursing us for
for the both the kit we're providing
uh and indeed you know the operational
cost which is which is what you would
expect and i think you know rishi
sunika's chancellor's definitely stood
by us on on those issues so right now in
the here and now we don't have a
challenge to our funding of course the
future is a different thing the the
effects of inflation on our budget but
also how far we want to go in support of
ukraine will of course of course have
costs but you know rishi's been
incredibly supportive on that and and
we're continuing on that direction would
you like to see more than the kind of
the 2.1 i think if you had any secretary
of state of any department sitting on
your sure but i've got you and asking
asking them if they'd like more money
for the department of course i'd like
more money for my department uh
labour secretary of state would say that
any sector
but you are let's be fair about it
and you are involved in a war and no
other government department is and you
have support you are supplying weapons
and and
and material to a war so just on that
basis
in the right now here and now for now
for this year's budget i am absolutely
set and for next year's you know we put
in a bid uh to the chancellor uh
for a four-year budget uh those first
two years are sort of over
i have always said as the threat changes
our demands change that can mean can go
up and down
what has changed since the integrated
review and indeed the defense command
paper is the threat has changed insofar
as while we identified russia is
basically the number one threat the fact
that president putin has gone even
further does make us all in a much more
insecure place and that's why the next
spending round and discussions about the
budget for the defense will of course
include how threat has changed but right
now you know the reforms to the armed
forces the support rishi is giving me
for ammunition etcetera means that we're
in a position where we can meet our
demand just reading this morning's kind
of defense intelligence briefing a focus
on the black sea and the fleet there and
i would suggest that you know 20 vessels
there is in part what we are considering
sending is at brimstone well yeah so the
reporting slightly amiss the brimstone
we are sending is the ground brimstone
right so that will be used over the
ground uh the the you have a different
type of brimstone for maritime but the
ones we're sending at the moment to that
but we have said we will source uh and
supply if we can
anti-ship missiles it's incredibly
important that the grain that affects us
all the food prices does get to get out
of ukraine that the russians can't
control the black sea it's not theirs
anymore that it is the turks and the
romanians the bulgarians but they think
somehow they can control it
and therefore making sure that the
russian ships are not used to bombard
cities is important um the minister
whenever we speak generally we spend the
vast majority of our time on your brief
today there are a couple of other
stories around i think demand a little
bit of attention um the high court
ruling yesterday in its judicial review
of of the the the unlawful nature of the
decision taken by matt hancock as
regards care homes is it finally time
for us to dispose of the notion as he
himself said that there was any sort of
a protective ring thrown around care
homes well i think look
let's cast our mind back and this is
really important to remember i remember
certainly you know again in the defense
space but there was a clamor for
assistance we were learning incredibly
fast about this this virus
it was coming thick and fast there were
massive concerns about the scale
of infection the death rates if you
remember the
about the same time everyone wanted
ventilators you know the medical advice
was ventilators what would be needed i
remember using the military to unpack
thousands of ventilators that that came
in from around the world and then
consequently we learned that that was
not really the key part of the treatment
so so that's why we're having this big
public inquiry that's why we're going to
have an inquiry into uh covert it's
really important we learn those lessons
of course that is a court case and a
court ruling uh matt hancock's put his
own statement outside he has i mean he
said he said that the the court case
comprehensively clears ministers of of
any wrongdoing the judgment said that
those uncharted had had simply failed
i mean
i've went through i don't know if you've
had the time to read the 75 page
judgment i did i read it last night and
despite mr hancock's characterization of
it comprehensively clearing ministers it
clearly states that he he acted
unlawfully and in doing so in not paying
heed to asymptomatic transmission of
covid19 people died in care homes well
look we've been very clear that we are
you know we apologize for all deaths
about in this that could have been
better handled i know matt did his own
interview recently saying he had some
regrets but i fundamentally i bet he
does well look look look imagine if we
kept asymmetric people in hospital what
would that have done uh to other
patients as well i mean this was not a
yes it happened in a care home setting
we took a lot of steps around care homes
if you remember we got criticized not so
long ago for insisting that you had to
be vaccinated to work in a care home
there was a huge amount of criticism i i
wouldn't say there was as much criticism
of the decision to send people
potentially with covert 19 into one of
the most risky environments for covert
transmission i mean the prime minister
repeated this statement yesterday prime
minister's questions that the government
had not been told about by public health
england about asymptomatic transmission
i mean that is just nonsense i want to
show you a quote from sir patrick
violence the chief scientific advisor
and he says this he was on the today
program on march the 13th that year he
said it looks quite likely that there is
some degree of asymptomatic transmission
there's definitely quite a lot of
transmission very early on in the
disease when there are very mild
symptoms he was talking about it i knew
about it my colleagues here at sky news
knew about it for the prime minister and
indeed the health secretary to maintain
that they knew nothing about it because
public health england didn't give them
an explicit warning i mean it's just
this court case proves that not to be
true well look i think as i've said
there is going to be an inquiry so we
can actually see the whole thing in
context we can we can study what you're
saying about whether the prime minister
and others were told we can see whether
they acted on it i certainly remember
using military personnel to try and take
testing to care homes so we could we
could make sure we
no one is denying that the armed forces
predicted no no no no no but it's not
judgmental
the point was the government did
recognize their issues and care homes
which is why they asked the army for
example to assist that i i think you
know look there's a court case i haven't
read the 75-page ruling uh you know it's
it you know
definitely the welfare of people in this
country is top of my agenda the prime
minister misled the house yesterday when
he said that he did not know about
asymptomatic transmission that was his
chief scientific advisor there well i
they just switched on the today program
and i'm not suggesting people do but you
know well i i think first and foremost
what i would say is that quote doesn't
talk about asymmetric it says mild
symptoms right so so some people have no
symptoms you had covid uh i mean
i will read it and we read it again it
looks quite likely there is some degree
of asymptomatic transmission yeah well
look look
i haven't read the report sure i've just
come on the program no i fully
understand it's a 75-page report matt
hancock's put a statement out we're
having a full inquiry to get to the
bottom of all the lessons learned to
have a look at what happened but i need
to just take you and your viewers back
to remember those stages what you know
it was unknown no one knew about the
variance you know we were learning fast
and furiously about exactly what to do
and there were many situations that will
almost lose lose if you were damned if
you did and you were damned if you
didn't and i think it's really important
to remember that you know the government
was also grappling at the time with do
we have enough ppe do we have enough
ventilated and all those things some of
those things turn out to be the wrong
course of effort based on advice or
based on no advice because i want any
and i think we should just not forget
the mass
worry in the state indeed of the
pandemic and of course you are not matt
hancock there is of course a standing
invitation of history mr hancock wants
to come on and explain himself but i do
want to ask about perhaps perhaps one of
the most ridiculous stories i have heard
in recent times that a conservative
colleague of yours was caught sitting in
the house of commons chamber next to
apparently a female minister watching
pornography
well there is no place for pornography
in any workplace i mean people are there
to do their job and you know i know that
the chief whip has referred that
complaint to
to the the panel or the or the conduct
authority and and look we'll look into
that and and if there's any action to be
done then there should be action taken i
don't think there's any excuse you don't
sit in your workplace looking at
pornography that's well your colleague
damian green did that's what got him
sacked from cabinet what
well there was a result there was
i'm just saying i'm just saying if any
party has formed for this is that
you know i used to hang on a sec i used
to uh
when i secured a minister my office and
has comments with john prescott's old
office where he had his christmas party
he was the deputy leader of the labour
party and if we all remember what that
wasn't pornography that was something
else that went on in that room i used to
wonder
i used to wonder if it was the same desk
so you know i i think let's just be
clear here
same with sexual conduct there's a range
of allegations that go right across the
house go right across the parties you
know this is a problem i think about the
overall culture of the house of commons
it is late sitting long nights with bars
and that very often leads and it has
done for decades to behavioral
challenges and problems whether that's
too much drink we've remembered reports
of you know why why do the armed forces
deal with this stuff better than you
know our elected representatives well
we still have problems in the armed
forces i mean you know look one of the
main missions of me is defense secretary
is we need to make the armed forces far
better for women
and their service we need to look after
complaints we need to take those
complaints seriously and action them
better we need to make sure we recruit
more women and make sure it's child care
friendly for families in the army all
those sort of things are really
important so
you know i don't i wouldn't say make
that comparison what i would say is you
know we all know what happens when you
mix long hours drink
and and pressure environment and i think
it's really important that we think
about ways to change the culture in the
house of commons so it doesn't happen
minister great to have you in the
program thanks for being with us thank
you